thank you charles all right welcome
everyone to today's meeting of the ovue
and scrutiny panel
both those that are participating and to
those of you who are watching from home
if you have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
democratic services officer on call who
will attempt to assist you
today's officer on call is charlotte
crowley and the number to call is
577-193
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
indicate on the chat
and i will then make a note and call you
when it is your turn
or if i miss your charles will remind me
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
for the duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
please can i ask the members of the
panel to confirm that they are present
in the meeting when i read out your name
councillor campbell present
councillor boyd president
david saunders substituting for
councillor coleman cook
present councillor hopkinson
council hopkinson
no yeah uh councillor huxley
president councillor keane
president can actually pat moore
present councillor paul moore
president councillor linda piper
yeah okay thank you councillor ratigan
councillor roper
councillor roper
no president chair
and councillor scott president chair
okay thank you i've not received any
prior requests to speak under 21
but are there any members who wish to
speak under 20.1
no i have not received any requests for
public speaking
okay members moving on to the agenda uh
gender item one apologies for absence
apologies have been received from the
following uh councillor coleman cook who
will be substituted by councillor david
saunders
are there any more apologies for absence
no thank you are there any declarations
of interest
okay moving on to a gender item three
minutes of the previous meeting
to approve the minutes of the overview
and scrutiny panel held on the 21st of
july 2020
a copy of which was attached to your
agenda pack can i have a proposer and a
seconder please
i propose councillor campbell thank you
councillor campbell
to find a seconder i would like to
second
cancer paul moore thank you councillor
moore
unless i hear any objection i will take
these as approved
as the silence was deafening i will
declare the minutes approved
thank you gender item 4
draft empty homes plan 2020 to 2023
i'll call upon councillor whitehead to
introduce the item for discussion
council whitehead
thank you very much chair sorry just
unmuting there
i often refer to housing as the
foundation for our duties and services
there's a good reason for this not only
does our housing approach cover many
separate sections
but the necessity of strong provision
also feeds into many community functions
tackling the issue of empty properties
is one such crossover
and is a fundamental part of our
approach
empty and derelict properties have an
adverse effect on neighborhoods
they are often unsightly and can attract
crime and antisocial behavior
such as squatting arson graffiti and fly
tipping
they may also affect the value of
neighbouring properties by creating an
impression of neglect and decline within
a community
such properties are not only eye soils
and a source of neighborhood distress
they are most significantly a wasted
resource in a time of ever-growing
housing demand many people cannot access
good housing
yet many homes stand vacant
homes that have been empty for more than
six months are of concern
and these are known as long-term empty
homes
the council's empty property team is
committed to taking action
wherever possible to help bring them
back into use
we do have a significant number of empty
homes within our area
however a more accurate measurement of
our aims and commitment within this
context
can be found within table 2 with vanet
outperforming all other councils within
kent
in terms of empty properties brought
back into use with 159
long-term empty homes brought back into
use via council's intervention
council intervention helps increase
overall housing supply
and reduces the negative environmental
and economic effects
that empty properties have on
neighbourhoods
this draft empty homes plan has been
prepared to address this issue long term
and provide strategies and approaches to
support us in bringing empty homes back
into use
the plan sets out the background to
empty homes and than it
highlights the main ways in which the
council can intervene
and explores the opportunities that
could be employed to help reduce the
number of long empty homes in bernard
we welcome any comments and suggestions
the overview and scrutiny panel may
have about the draft plan thank you very
much
thank you councillor whitehead
councillor campbell
uh thank you very much chair yes just a
few queries
page six uh the table on page six
includes men what the medway uh in the
uh
uh in the empty homes uh
sorry in the uh long-term empty homes in
kent
uh on pa on page seven uh the table does
not include midway
in a particular i'm not particularly
criticizing but if you're going to
include it in six
in seven empty homes brought back into
using kent
then you need to include midway in both
or neither
i would suggest
thank you thank you can i just confirm
that councillor roper has joined the
meeting
yes i have uh apologies i i was given
two different timings uh on an email
i've got but uh i'm here now
okay thank you councillor casa whitehead
sorry back to you
that's fine hello cancer rapper um yes
councillor campbell um it's probably
best that i refer to
mr hopkins at this point um as he
prepared the table
yeah mr hopkins uh hello there yeah
um the reason why uh midway is not in
the second table is we work closely with
kent county council and their no use
empty campaign
and it is kent county council that
collect all the data across
kent and because medway is a is a
unitary authority
they don't collect that data but the
data in the previous table is available
on a government website
okay uh on page 10
uh it states that an empty property is
given a band c
rating as high i think this is a typo it
should be band a
that's rated as high
sorry uh what page was that page 10 page
10
where it actually gives the numbers for
the actual um
a b and c it's got
c rating high in actual fact it's a
that's rated high
not c uh yes that is indeed correct i'm
not quite sure what happened there
let me just have a look um
[Music]
yeah now that is an error yeah
absolutely correct though it is a
is the high rating okay
you get a star for that councillor
campbell thank you very much
um what i'm confused about within the
plan it mentions
in various places empty properties
brought back into use
and then it just mentions empty
properties now is there a
differentiation between empty properties
brought back into use
and simply empty properties i mean empty
properties can include
of properties that have never been
actually let
should there be some consistency or is
there a or is there a difference
in the um empty properties brought back
into use and empty properties
um in terms of the term empty home
because we're a housing we're in the
housing section so we
focus on empty homes and um uh
empty properties the vast majority of
the work that we do
is um empty homes that were previously
homes
uh that have obviously become empty but
there are some occasions where um
sometimes that while we use a generic
term is that there's a property that may
have been
commercial or something that it clearly
isn't going to be commercial anymore as
in
it is in a derelict state and then we
look at it and if we think it
potentially could be residential and
that's probably the way it's going to go
we would include that in our
intervention program and try and bring
that back into use
as as as a property as a home so
the term empty homes is primarily
because um
we're looking to bring them back in to
residential but we use the term empty
property because sometimes we look at
other um we even sometimes look at
pieces of derelict land which
had a property on it that's been uh
demolished and we tried to get something
uh you know built on that site for
residential use
does this include new builds as well
um uh it well
i mean generally not i mean if if there
was a new build it
if um if it was empty i'd be quite
surprised but yeah i mean if it's been
empty for more than six months then
we would intervene yeah okay uh also on
the last one on page 44
you talk about uh the demolition of
listed building
um you would still take it back as a
dco isn't the uh demolition of enlisted
building a criminal offence
uh without permission i'm sure i'm sure
it would be yes um
what page was that on again sorry page
44
ah uh right i'm sorry is that that
that's in my you know what page on the
report it is sorry
in the report page 44 in the plan
in the draft plan oh the item all right
paragraph 44 yeah
para 44 sorry yeah yeah yeah
sorry about that i've lost the star
right yeah yeah
um yeah so um
yeah obviously if you were to uh
demolish the list of building block
consent that would
would be it would be an offense for our
planning enforcement team to get
involved in
um the reason why it's been put in here
is that sometimes
empty homes can be listed buildings and
um you know there are various ways that
you can
um achieve a compulsory purchase order
and enlisted buildings what usually
happens is you have to uh
serve a listed building's repair notice
first
as a process towards going towards a
compulsory purchase order
yes okay thank you thanks
thank you council huxley
thanks chair thanks richard for the
report
uh the plan it's really useful um
does uh the tgc database
that you talk about the empty properties
database does it include empty shops
and empty flats above shops
if it doesn't can that be put in and
also
could you include brownfield sites
there's a lot in the town centres in the
three towns
i mean i know in east cliff ward for
example at least
five brownfield empty sites have been
like that for about 30 years
thanks
um i think we do include
brownfield sites in terms of monitoring
um and flats of course would be included
i'm not entirely sure about in relation
to shops so
um again i'll refer to mr hopkins at
this point
yes um so the uh the database so we have
a proprietary database
um system and then we can add anything
to
to to that system so a lot of the data
we collect
is uh is from the obvious source which
is council tax data
but we also respond uh to referrals from
from from council like yourself or
members of the public uh and
if it's um you know um
you know a space above a shop that could
be
could be residential we we think that's
the case then we'd have certainly add
that to our um
our list uh our system and there are
some
sites on um our uh
system uh and we do try to monitor them
they are
a lot more complicated for us um because
the powers are very limited uh for us
and empty empty homes
um intervention is not a statutory
function as such
and um and and of course one of the main
things it's not unlawful to have
an empty home so it can be quite
complicated but
yeah we do try where we can and where we
have
uh an owner that's really not playing um
or helping us it
can be quite difficult but where we have
got some
empty sites and we can try and convince
and and
one of the main things that we try to do
is to help out with um
no use empty loans through our partners
county council
so we will endeavor to do so but
certainly
the system that we have incorporates
cash for tax data as well as our own
data that we've included
okay thanks thank you a councillor boyd
thank you chair and just a couple of
points although most of my things have
been covered by a councillor campbell
unfortunately
and i'm missing out on the gold star um
but
have we approached other councils such
as darth vader who had a kind of
consistent performance
in terms of um dealing with empty homes
so have we approached other councils
like them to see what else they are
doing get good practice
and then my other question is around the
interest-free loans and why there's such
a slow turnaround
what's the average loan given out and
also because there's a clause about the
occupiers staying there for five years
and are they actually fulfilling that
requirement
yeah in relation to the specifics i'll
refer to
mr hopkins at this point um as we'll
have access to
the data relating to that
um yes thank you uh in terms of uh
dartford uh we know that the
the offices at dartford very well um
although i don't attend the meeting
myself um there is a kentwide empty
property officers
network and they meet i think it's
quarterly
and they obviously share ideas and we'll
work together
and the good thing is that in in kent
obviously excluding including medway
we can have a very uh strong um
small team uh that is working with all
kent local authorities to try and
uh intervene and bring empty hands back
into use
um so yes so we do uh work closely with
our
with our neighbours and uh i i do so as
well because i'm
the chair of the kent housing technical
group so yeah
we work with author all 13 local
authorities yeah
um uh in terms of sorry my memory is not
what it used to be uh what was the
second point
uh interest-free loans i think uh
yes um
so um so what's been happening for a
long long time of course
is the interest-free loans uh that is um
not intended for owner occupiers
that's intended for landlords or
developers who are going to buy a
property and then sell it on because the
idea was
it's a it's a kent county council five
million pound recyclable fund
um and if people don't pay that back
because it's needed for the recyclable
fund it was always seen that
um it would be a bit difficult if an
owner occupier particularly a vulnerable
person was in there
to try and you know um sort of repossess
that house because the loan wasn't being
paid back so that was
why kent county council go
for this more developer and landlord
situation um and we have uh been
um i think we have uh
taken nearly a third of all the funding
that's been available for the 12 local
authorities in the kent
area um for fannie and actually
this year um we have already um
uh uh i think approved 11 loans uh in
fanet since the first of april so we've
had
our best sort of quarter so far uh in
terms of um
the owner occupier loans um there was a
small amount of money
uh that was made available uh for this
scheme uh a little while back
um and what we what we wanted to do is
is to do something in addition to what
is offered across kent
so no other local authority offers these
owner occupier loans
um so uh a maximum of 20
uh 20 000 pounds um of course the
the the budget isn't particularly large
uh
and um that uh budget part is it's
primarily exhausted and obviously it's
going to take some time to recycle that
money because of them
obviously regular repayments and it
would and uh
but yes um that they're only
relatively recent and the ones i'm aware
of and there's no there's been no
breaches of
of the um of the occupation
um grant well loan condition and i
suspect there won't be
but you know in the event that um that
there was then potentially uh
we could use our legal powers to um to
reclaim some of that money
sorry was it was there any other
questions on that no thank you
all right councillor boyd that's great
thank you
okay thank you um
thank you um yeah just a question do we
need a publicity drive to get
people identifying empty homes i kind of
in my memory seem to think that we've
had this kind of thing before
um do we need another one and just as a
sort of point
on the thanet council website
if you go to report an empty property it
underneath that it says find out more
information
but it doesn't do anything so perhaps we
need to add something to that as well
yeah i think that's a very important
point
actually thinking in terms of publicity
in general
it's obviously useful getting people to
notice and people to report
but i think publicity just in terms of
what we actually do
in terms of empty property is really
useful
a lot of the external narrative
regarding empty homes is that
unfortunately is that we're not seen to
be very active and that we're not doing
things
when in fact as if you look at table two
we're very active and we were
the best in terms of the kent councils
in terms of bringing empty properties
back into use so i think
it's worth publicizing just how
successful
we are at this particular area and that
we do have a dedicated team for this
um and that if homes are reported
action is taken and we are doing
everything we can to bring those
properties back into use
um i don't know if there's anything that
mr hopkins wants to add at this point
um yeah i mean uh i don't i need to
reiterate your points and also that we
have um
when we were approached for um
television we usually get involved in
that
so um the last one we did was about
i think it was a year or two ago with uh
matt all right from
uh who usually from watchdog bbc one uh
he did a program on empty homes and uh
he came down and and featured some of
the work that we did on on bbc one
um we did some uh publicity uh about a
year a year and a bit
maybe a little bit more um we we
uploaded some
video video um my empty prophecy
our empty property officer did but
there's always room for more and
you know it probably is time to um um
you know maybe do a little bit more um
and in terms of the website link yeah
i'll certainly look at that and get that
sorted out
okay thank you hey councillor campbell
uh thank you chair yes just an offer
really uh ramsgate town council
i like to gather in every meeting has a
community ad magazine that goes out to
eighteen thousand residents
uh of ramsgate uh they're looking at the
moment for articles
uh to actually fill the magazine and i'm
sure if you
either councillor whitehead or or mr
hopkins would cut i would
contact dean williams at ramsgate town
council custom house
uh they could uh put a little put an
article in
the community ad magazine highlighting
what rams what sonic district council
has done to bring uh empty homes back
into use and also ask residents to
report any empty homes that they can see
in in ramsgate
that seems to me to be an excellent idea
and i'm more than happy
to do that okay thank you
okay i can't see any other members at
the moment so i've got a couple of
comments and questions that i would like
to ask
um i mean i think the first point to
make is that um i seem to remember that
the empty homes team has actually been
recognized
sort of nationally as being good at what
it does um
not sure if they've won awards they've
certainly been nominated for awards
um and i think you know those figures
showing how many properties we brought
back into use is a real credit to them
and that should be recognized
um our first question i suppose is i'm
not sure what i understand
a bit of it correctly it revolves around
these
owner occupier loans and i
it seemed to suggest that there was a
waiting list for
owner occupy lines and i wondered how
that can be because
surely it would be somebody who's
identified an empty home
needing work doing to it that it wants
to buy if they've got to go on a waiting
list
that property they're looking to buy
might not be there so have i
misunderstood something there
um i'll refer over to mr hopkins at this
point
yeah it it it is uh uh yeah it is a
slightly
unusual situation uh because if you want
to buy a property
that's more than six months empty so you
can
uh you know essentially renovate it move
in
uh you've got a window of opportunity
and unfortunately the situation
as it is that if without any money um
it you know remaining in the pot we
can't offer a loan at that time but what
we do do
uh is is essentially take a note of
their details
and if if the money does become
available in the near future we'll we'll
get in contact with them
and off and see whether the property is
still for sale that
do they still want to buy it do they
still want the loan and we will try and
uh
organize something with them but yeah
there is a situation where people may
ask there's no money and then by the
time that money is available
uh potentially the property is gone or
you know
not for sound or something okay thank
you
um i noticed that uh the plan includes
uh targets with the targets going up at
10
homes per year being brought back into
use
but 160 homes i mean we compare very
favorably to other districts so it seems
to me we're already doing quite well
so question around targets is are they
actually realistic
or is it just you know put in there
to sort of indicate some some idea of
progress i mean
how have we actually arrived at the
thought that we would do another 10
homes a year
um so um what what's happened
um uh uh in in in recent uh in the last
year is that
um we had a target
for a little while of about 120 125
um but we didn't have an empty property
officer for for a little while
uh but that that person um uh started in
2017
and they've gradually because to be fair
empty property work is really
really specialized there's very few
people around that do it so
what generally happens is you get
someone who has transferable skills
and then you train them and they get
better and better so
um so the gentleman that we have at the
moment has been with us for a couple of
years now and is getting better
and also um we have um
uh the support officer role um
is now gone to job share um where before
it was just about one person
uh now we have someone who's coming
who's um uh
who is quite dynamic he's a he's a
former police
detective sergeant and he's very very
keen to get
involved as much as he can and
when i prepared this plan i i felt that
there
there was scope um with uh the new
um the team as it sits now to to try and
push a little bit further
can't guarantee it um but i i think
uh the staff involved were happy uh with
the targets i proposed
and are looking forward to trying to
achieve them okay thank you
i mean on the same theme really um you
as you've just
uh indicated we only have two officers
and i don't know whether
there would be a natural sort of
correlation that if we had another
officer we would bring more properties
back into you so
i i appreciate that you know there's a
great social value
to bringing houses back into use but is
there any way of demonstrating
some kind of cost benefit to the council
so that a case could be made for an
extra officer to be
appointed
i'm not sure how i can see how it could
be
quantifiable in some way but i'm not
sure how we
measure it directly um
obviously um all for more resources
going to housing
unsurprisingly um so if there are
measurables that we can use in that way
that would be very
interesting but i'll check i'd like to
refer over to mr hopkins to see
if there are measurables that we could
use in that sense
okay thank you as a sort of contrary to
that
um it appears that uh in the future we
may be able to charge
people 400 council tax on empty
properties
which could be seven thousand a year um
do we want to bring those properties
back into you so would we rather
you know that the local authorities got
the the seven thousand pounds
again i think you're looking at the
interplay between
social games and financial gains and yes
of course financial gains can result in
social gains
um we want functioning
communities we want healthy communities
with established populations
um and we are woefully short
in terms of housing and we need to get
as many people on our list housed as
possible
and so i think the ultimate aim is
always to make sure the properties are
used
um i do think it's significant in terms
of a national intervention that we can
now do this
and that we can raise council tax for
those that are
empty long term um
but for me and i think i would imagine
the rest of the housing team the aim
is always to make sure that any property
that can be used
is used because it benefits our
community as a whole
okay thank you i wasn't being entirely
serious with the question i've got to
say but
what i do well i think it's a serious
question i noticed that
um we've got in in the uh the sort of
targets and that our actions
so on we've got um going after edmo's
edm edmos
and the body of the report suggests that
they're difficult if not impossible to
do
so the question is is there any point in
pursuing them
might officers be better engaged in
going after perhaps softer targets
um mr hopkins how do you feel in terms
of targets
in that area and proportionally
resource wise absolutely uh point well
made
because um we have tried
um um one ed mode before and we spent an
awful lot of time and resources uh going
to the tribunal
and it had been an empty property for
many years uh and um
on on the day of the uh five billion
viewing uh they
they turned up with a few rugs and a few
chairs and put it in and said we're
about to move in
and um it's a very challenging situation
um and an awful lot of time and
resources went into it
and then subsequently uh the law was
changed to make it even harder
uh to get edmonds they have to be empty
for two years there has to be lots of
um complaints about it and the tribunals
are very reluctant
um to give them uh to be honest
um and most local authorities
uh that have even have actually
successfully
done that found that the resource that
no not only once you've um
once you've got an edmo uh then you've
got to put all the resources in to try
and
renovate it and the cost and expense at
the council's expense
um then you've got to get it let and
then in the first year you can't get it
let without the
uh owner's approval um
you can do a final uh final edmo which
gives you a bit longer another seven
years uh and where
you can let it but um in terms of
monetary everything that you put into it
you have to put into it
from as a local authority's point of
view and if you don't
um if you make any surplus you have to
give it back to the owner
and if you make any loss the council has
to bear that loss
and that can be quite problematic um
and what what i think the spirit of what
we were trying to say in this report is
that if there is
a specific case where perhaps an edmo
might not be too much of a financial
risk for the council and it could happen
and that we could resource it um then
we perhaps look to do it but it it it's
going to be
more of a um sort of a disincentive more
of a
would use the publicity for it you know
to demonstrate how that
potentially we could do this but the
reality is if i asked
uh the two officers that we had to do
nothing but edmo's
then we would achieve some really good
things but our our
um outputs each year were probably
dropped at five or ten rather than 160.
so
when you say the soft target it's the
easier ones you're absolutely right
because
um but we have to balance it with uh
with
enforcement and the soft target it's
very difficult but
i think if there's a an obvious
opportunity and some problems we would
consider
we're considered trying to do one but
it's not going to be many that's for
sure
okay well i mean following on from that
i'm going to go back to my original
point i mean
is it should we not take it out of the
program and and it'd be a sort of
windfall if
officers come across it or if we're
going to leave it in
should we perhaps caveat it with the
kind of uh
you know words that you just use about
sort of go after it
provided that it looks like one that's
easy to do because otherwise
we just seem to be setting ourselves uh
you know
the opportunity to fail
i mean i'll leave it there i mean i
don't there's nothing i think you're
right i mean we could uh we could um
uh change the terminology in the report
um if that's what's
uh agreed um to to suggest that you know
where it's appropriate and practical you
know that we would do it and not just
simply go looking for them yeah
okay thank you um my final points to
question actually
um i think the report also said that you
know the
the favored way is to go for in full
sail
question is does tdc get its costs
covered when it gets involved in
full sales
mr hopkins i think you do but i don't
want to
so absolutely yes um so uh with an
enforcer
um the only the downsides of enforcer
um is that we are um we have to keep the
money in perpetuity
so we must keep it forever and in case
there's a claim but
what we can do is um
so for example there was one that comes
to mind where building control had to
put lots of um
scaffolding up for a number of years and
that's do some repairs
and then when we forced us out of that
property we managed to recoup all that
money
uh and deduct it from what was owed
to the owner yeah thank you thank you
very much
um i don't see any other members wanting
to speak on this item
council campbell are you indicating are
you just waving to me
okay just what just waving okay fine
in that case members i'd
ask you to note the report
and ask that officer take away our
comments
and consider any points that arise from
that
that been suggested that you may include
in the finished product
noted okay is that agreed members
agreed thank you thank you very much
thank you mr hopkins for that thank you
uh right moving on now to agenda item
five
tenant and lease holder service
transition update
council white head back in the spotlight
again
hello again um there we are
bringing our housing provision back
in-house is one of our most significant
tasks as a council currently
and is one that's been very ably managed
by housing
this report covers the progress that's
being made towards bringing the housing
management and maintenance service
currently provided by east kent housing
back in house
the key points it covers are how we are
ensuring that we have enough staff to
run the service
from the 1st of october how we intend to
induct
transitioning and new staff giving them
the best introduction possible to the
council
and the new service how we are informing
and involving tenant and leaseholder
representatives in the transitioning of
the service
and our intention to keep them involved
going forward
the ongoing work by ict to separate the
housing management system between the
four
councils and supporting staff in their
training on new systems
the work being undertaken by the
communications team
to keep staff and customers informed of
the changes
and finally the winding up of east kent
housing
how we manage this transition and how
involved tenants and leaseholders are in
this process
is extraordinarily important the basis
for continued success of an in-house
system
is providing a secure base and competent
and coherent systems
to manage our ongoing responsibilities
and i am very pleased to be able to say
that the ongoing work in this area by
housing has been exemplary
this is a very exciting time and also a
hugely significant one
we are laying the foundations for our
ongoing relationship with our tenants
and these holders
and setting the ground for our abilities
as a landlord going forward
i'm hugely proud to be part of housing
as they complete this work
and i can't praise them enough for their
commitment making this process fully
inclusive and reflective
and we welcome any questions
do any members have any comments or
questions they'd like to raise
in which case there's a couple of points
that i would like to raise
i was very positive report but could i
ask what if anything
is not going to plan at the moment
obviously i'd like to defer to mrs
sullivan in in relation to
how she's managing the transition as she
is the manager of this
um i can express what some of my
concerns
are currently in the run-up to the first
of october
um and a lot of that relates to how we
wind up the service
and how tenants and leaseholders feel
listened to
and have works attended to across this
period
because obviously it's quite a difficult
one in terms of staff changeover and
handover
in a personal sense i've been managing
that by trying to be
as proactive as possible and on-site as
possible
when it comes to our blocks um
but i know that we're doing everything
we can to make sure that this
transitional period functions as well as
it can do
um and for the specifics of the
situation i'd like to hand over to ms
sullivan
thank you um so things that
that aren't going as as planned or we
are trying to plan
mitigating against risk um has to be to
do with the accommodation of staff at
the council offices
and the reason that's posing a bit of a
problem at the moment is
due to um covert 19
and the the mitigation that's put in
place
to ensure that the council is covert
secure means that there is not as much
space um for staff or not the
opportunity for as many staff
to be in the council offices at one time
this is having a knock-on effect on our
program from induction as well
meaning that we have to split the new
staff into groups to ensure they receive
their new equipment and receive
induction and welcome as they come to
the council on the 1st of october
the other area which is not going to
plan
has to be ict
there have been delays due to the
complexity
of the
novation documents
and change control notes which are
highly complex and need a lot of
revision
and that has caused delays overall to
our ict plan
to mitigate this and luckily if the ict
side of things does fall behind this
does not pose too much of a threat to
go live on the 1st of october the staff
can still run the frontline
services without having the ict
in in the position that we would like it
to be in
okay um i mean do you have any worries
uh that the first of october deadline
won't be met i mean presumably it has to
happen on the 1st of october so
the consequence would be that the
service would not be
sort of up and running properly i mean
do you have any fears in that regard
i have no worries in that regard the
service will come over on the 1st of
october
we have been very fortunate in the um we
have some very good people coming over
from east kent housing that cover
all of the vital areas in the housing
management service
and this means that in terms of having
an operational handover and a caseload
handover
we are having individual meetings with
the staff that are coming to us to make
sure that that work is brought with them
and that they are fully prepared for the
first of october as to what's
what they're going to be doing from that
date the meetings i've had so far in
terms of operational handover with
individual staff have been very positive
and i feel confident that they will be
able to bring that workload with them
okay thank you that that's very
encouraging um another question
um of the east kent housing staff that
moving across are we getting uh across
the thanat the number of staff that we
expected
are you happy for me to answer
councillor whitehead uh
yes no more than happy thank you yes
uh so we in our new structure we are
getting just over 50 of the amount of
staff that we need
um obviously this would not be enough to
run the service and we
have uh been running a very large
recruitment campaign
in which we have now appointed most
people to the service
our service managers have started
already and this has given them a really
good head start in being able to
organize their teams as they want to and
start taking a look at the processes and
procedures
that the um service will be running by
so i feel confident that we have we'll
have the staff in place for the first of
october
to be able to run the service thank you
and my final uh question really on this
is
um do you anticipate that the transition
costs will stay within the 250
000 pound budget that was agreed by
cabinet i think back in july
yes uh yes
we went forward carefully to make sure
you stop it yes
hello yes um we talked about in
involving um tenants and
leaseholders etc i just wondered what
method have you been using to
involve them and have you got much in
the way of feedback are they all
happy and delighted that it's being
brought into house or are there some
particular worries um
we've been having much more regular
tenant and leaseholder
meetings um
which i think at this point is
absolutely essential um
the key to this service will be making
sure that it's a service
that is reflective of our tenants that
it's something that they want
and it's something that they have input
into
in terms of how it functions um so we've
been meeting very regularly to talk
about what they want
from an ongoing system um what they need
what they felt that they haven't had
previously
and a lot of the feedback has revolved
around
communication feeling heard making sure
that
they can track what's happening with
jobs that need doing making sure that
they feel heard by people that
are representing them in that area and
we're looking forward to being able to
address those
issues with the online interface so that
tenants can
manage their housing needs quite
effectively and see
exactly what's happening and with who
and who the
job is with at what point um
at the moment um with every meeting that
i've had people have seen very
optimistic and very happy
um we are aware and they are aware that
they're
the transition itself can be a difficult
process
but everybody at this point is seeming
quite optimistic and hopeful and
i honestly believe that with the team
that we have in place to deliver this
and the commitment that we have to
listening to tenants
and this stands to be a very very
positive development
thank you councillor campbell
oh yes thank you chair um given we are
where we are taking the service
back in-house is in no longer uh small
part
due to the terrible service provided by
east camp housing
um is there a process for monitoring the
transition of the service
and the ongoing service provided by the
in-house service
if so what is it and what difference is
the service
that we're offering uh to the service
that offered by east kent housing
i'd like to speak to this initially if
that's okay um
i think and no disrespect
to at all to staff within east kent
housing because i think they've
worked exceptionally hard um i think the
difference
to my mind that there needs to be
is that the service needs to be coherent
there needs to be a greater level of
communication across all areas
um i think our focus on having people
who are responsible for
particular areas or for particular
geographical
sports is it vital um
but i think the overriding
importance here is communication
we can't provide an effective service if
we're not listening
and if we're not paying attention and if
we haven't put together a system that
allows
tenants and leaseholders to have an
active role in what they want from their
housing and what they need from us
um and i think that's where we stand
to differ and i think that's where our
systems stand to differ
um but i would like to refer to mr
sullivan at this point for
further details thank you um
so to echo what council white had said
in terms of communication um and how
how are we how we're going to make it
better is once the service is in-house
we'll be
have the opportunity to take stock of
um what is being offered currently
um our intention is to review the
service in its entirety and come up with
an action plan which would be
fully bought into by our tenants and
leaseholder representatives as well
and to execute this plan and to be able
to monitor the plan with the
tenant and leaseholders to ensure that
the improvements that we
visualize are being put into place and
that they are making a difference
as the service transitions um we will be
getting the quarter two
um performance indicators from east kent
housing and i intend to use this as a
baseline
to see where performance is at currently
so that we can monitor going forward
the performance using uh key performance
indicators
thank you chair i wonder if i could just
add something yep of course
mr williams i i would just um
like to say that part of the success of
the transition so far was down to the
transition
project manager which was sally
o'sullivan and then we were
very pleased to appoint her just
recently to the as the tenant and
leaseholder service manager
so that really is i think is a great
appointment
and also it helps with transition the
continuity from the transition to
actually running the service
i think also i'd say one of the reasons
why
east kent housing wasn't as successful
as it could have been
was down to the model i think
that the model of running housing
services on a shared service basis or
through an elmo i think that did present
some obstacles
which were in some ways nobody's fault
and i think some of the objectives and
focus
and priorities that we had as a council
regarding our running our
our housing service didn't always
translate
into on the ground with east kent
housing
and by bringing it in-house i think
we'll overcome some of those
some of those obstacles and i would also
say that we've uh
we're very mindful of the risk of the
service deteriorating during the period
of transition
it was on our risk register and we've
been trying to address that throughout
the process
and finally looking forward apart from
coming up with an action plan where we
can use as a baseline where we are now
i think we can also see in the capital
program there's a huge amount of
investment going into the housing stock
over the next two to three years
okay yeah thank you mr willis yeah the
point's well made
um so could i thank you uh mr sullivan
for coming along
tonight sorry have i missed your
counselor campbell
again you're not about oh yeah okay yeah
we wouldn't get rid of you that easy so
i think another major failing of uh
the uh east kent pounding housing um
paradigm model uh was that it was based
upon
saving money yeah only that was the
major con
constraint that it had to year on year
save money um is this a particular
uh feature of the new model and it's now
brought in house
i do hope not thank you councillor
campbell
would you like to address that mr willis
or would you like to leave it hanging
i would like to say that a a presumption
of saving money does not
is not mutually exclusive for delivering
service
i think the council has been running for
years with diminishing resources
and i think we've improved our services
over the medium to long term
so i think that's just a fact of life
unfortunately in local government so i'm
not offering any guarantees that
that the council will be increasing
resources in in
in the way we manage our social housing
because the hra suffers many of the same
difficulties as a general fund so i
can't make any promises about that but i
can say
that within the resources that we have
available we'll be delivering
a better service than has existed in the
recent past
thank you mr willis i've got to say i
don't think there's anything wrong with
having cost savings as one of the
objectives of the elmo but but there you
go
um so give me a chance to thank you a
second time mr sullivan for coming along
thank you very much anderson willis
and councillor whitehead uh thank you
very much as always a pleasure to have
you with us
thank you very much thank you thank you
and good night
um right members moving on to uh
we have no post issues in scrutiny
tonight so we move on to agenda item six
which is a review of the isp work
program i think you'll find the
paperwork for this on the supplementary
agenda is that right charles
yes that's correct chairman it's in the
supplementary
okay thank you
okay um before
we we're starting out i would just like
to give members an update because
our last uh scrutiny meeting we uh
suggested that we would set up a working
party to look at the issues of
um memorial statues blue plaques etc
following on the the uncle max situation
that we had in broad stairs
on police report that we now
um have uh set that uh working party up
we've got all the
the names of the members um i hope that
the first meeting will take place in the
early part of september
uh so we can get it going there what i
would say that uh
somebody i think it might have been um
cancer wing or cancer ghana
suggested that um it might be an idea
that we included
michelle thomas in the working party um
but uh the thought was that uh it would
be up to the working party to decide if
they would like to bring in
uh witnesses uh when they're addressing
the way forward with with this
uh policy uh and so that's what we're
gonna do
one thing that was quite encouraging um
we were
we looked at a list of memorials and
plaques and statues and something that
we've got around
the district and it was quite pleasing
to note that i
don't think that we've got many that are
controversial i mean councillor campbell
you've
seen the list as well i don't know with
you you've got any comment on that
you you muted councillor campbell
now you're quite right there councillor
uh bayford i
i didn't see many contentious in my view
many contentious uh issues but i'm sure
there's going to be some
that are going to discover that there
are highly contentious issues
around tania but to my cursor review of
the list
there didn't seem to be many as far as i
was concerned but i'm not historian
and i don't know the social background
to a lot of these people
okay yeah thank you council campbell um
at this stage
i'd like to thank charles and nick for
the work they put in because they
actually um
put the um various suggested work
streams
um scrutiny items uh through the price
prioritization uh matrix that they've
got
uh and that's been reproduced in the
papers that you have and there's been a
ranking applied to them
the first question really with members
um are you
happy with that list happy with the the
ranks as they come out or
are there any uh issues that you have
with with that list or the way it's been
put together
i thought i recalled bob uh i requested
on the
initial um when you called for
subjects for meeting uh about your
leisure
i see that's not on the list at all
right um yeah i i
i i can't remember that uh councillor
ezekiel you you you may well be right
and there's no reason why we can't add
that to the list
um did you actually uh respond
to the request uh that if you like the
sort of questions that you would want
answered um
were known because that that was key to
to drawing up the prioritization list
i haven't seen anything on that at all
bob there was an email went out from i
think it was from charles
asking people to uh you know support
the items that they put forward with the
questions they would like answered
so that they could actually determine
the way scrutiny would go you know what
what would be the results
needed to look at it so perhaps if you
could do that if you could write to
charles and tell him
you know that the things about your
leisure that you would like
are scrutinized
okay thank you very much okay
uh any other members got any questions
about that
or comments about the prioritization
list
counselor campbell here yeah yeah yeah i
fully appreciate the fact that there's
an extensive list
and there's extensive prioritization the
only problem i can see from the work
program that we're actually looking at
in this agenda item is there's very
little time
for us to actually scrutinize any of
these
we're running into sort of budget and
other considerations
and and cabinet member scrutiny uh that
we will perhaps need to
encourage the cabinet member responsible
for the service
that we need to be scrutinized that was
identified
to discuss that as a major topic of
their uh scrutiny uh
uh performance yeah that's
quite well made councillor campbell um
if you look at the list the
the top three on on that list came out
as coastal waste
clearance a replacement of litter and
dog bins
and managing anti-social behavior on
beaches
which was third equal with empty
properties and i think empty property
we've done something tonight towards
that so whether that needs to stay on
the list
we can think about but would members be
happy
that we look to try and include
those top three ranking ones in
you know the upcoming scrutiny meetings
again i would take silence as your
approval and i noticed him housing
council uh no sorry nick hughes you you
you you're waving at me
i assume you'd like to speak very much
chairman if that's okay with you
um i think these the the table that
that's there in in annex
ii that we've that you've referred to um
these these are topics for scrutiny
reviews
so they're not really designed to be
topics considered
by the whole panel they're designed to
be like
so you'd have what members collectively
refer to as a working party
on it so a bit like we did with the
travelers
if that makes sense so um by all means
as i say
absolutely great that so many members
have put
a wide and varied selection of things
that people want
to talk about and that's great that's
really really good um and as you've said
before with council forzeki we can add
things to this we can take this list off
this is very much the first stage of a
much longer process
and i think the other thing i would
really want to make clear to members is
that
the the list of stuff that we see here
is not a work
program for maybe six months or the
second half of this year
this could be two three four years of
work that could well see out
the uh the lifetime of this this council
uh this uh of this council the up until
2023
um so it could be the case that if you
wanted to
to um look towards um
setting up a uh a scrutiny review
on the the three topics or one of those
three topics
um we could we could look to do that bob
bear in
my own mind the fact that um resources
at this time of of covid
uh are uh focused on uh
the coded response so just bear that in
mind when we're looking at that and and
if we're going to pick something that
has um
a particular impact on the areas of the
council that are dealing with
um uh the coded response then obviously
do bear that in mind when choosing
uh the the topics that you want to to
look at first of all
okay thank you nick yeah i mean i think
my thought was really
talk about bringing them to scrutiny was
really that you know we put them on an
agenda
and we discussed whether we want to set
a working party up at that particular
point in time
and that can be done in conjunction with
um
you know you've given us guidance as the
results that's available and so on
i think council campbell's point is also
well made if there's any items in there
with a bit of tweaking can be covered in
cabinet member uh reports to scrutiny
we can do that so on that
basis our members happy to to
agree that
agreed okay thank you very much okay
uh in in which case um we we've
commented on the report uh will members
now please note it
noted thank you uh agenda item seven
uh now unless there is something from
the plan that
panel would particularly wish to
consider at this moment
members are asked to note the report
noted thank you is that agreed members
i'll take your silencers agreement a few
people are nodding which is great
um so can i take this opportunity to
thank you for your attendance tonight
and your contribution
and wish you all a very good evening
thank you